[Music]
welcome to what I think is number 36 in
this monthly series a worlds of
speculative fiction so we're doing
Tanith lee somebody who I hadn't read
for a very long time you sort of picked
to do and I'm really happy that that I
did because the Flat Earth books are
quite good and very enjoyable we have
some themes since we have the truck that
not truck or dry erase board I thought
I'd make use of it for once up on there
but I'm sure you'll have some other
philosophical themes that you want to
bring up as well
I created a number of a number of
passages that I called it's actually
difficult to complete her timeline
imperfect is there there's not a lot of
biographical material as such out there
and because she died recently as soon as
you search there's a million different
obituaries
all talking about different things all
drawing on like the same Wikipedia you
know and very few of them supplying much
information so you got to go into like
the interviews that she has to glean
very much and I thought you know we'd
start as we usually do with talking
about her biography and then the
world-building
obviously this is this is an interesting
you know world because it's it's not
it's not a globe alright it's literally
a flat earth like a bunch of cakes on
top of each other but she says that it
this is like before the world became
became round so so it's a set in the
distant past and you know as I was
researching her story and we were
talking about this before the start it's
really interesting how economics and
Jean Roach is one of the things I wanted
to talk about as a philosophical theme
impacted her in her work she found
herself at one point in what she
actually called a desperate situation as
an established author unable to sell
manuscripts somebody who'd won prizes
had been nominated for for many more so
well we'll come to that so she's you
know born in 47 and in London she
clarifies in one of her interviews that
her parents were ballroom and latin
dancers not like you know dancers in
other genres that I think people had
taken it as being and apparently there
was a guy Bernard Lee who was in some
way connected with the James Bond
stories and she also had to clarify many
times that he wasn't that Bernard D and
she ended up moving around quite a bit
with her family in the 50s so she'd
change schools pretty frequently said
she got bullied quite a bit and later on
in life you know they didn't have very
good classifications for these things at
the time she talks about being diagnosed
as dyslexic she didn't learn to read
effectively until she was 8 and
apparently her father was exasperated
and decided he was going to buckle down
and teach her how to read because the
teachers couldn't help her read and they
were both literate people though their
parents so they wanted her to be able to
read and then once she started reading
and it took her about a month to learn
she just started you know voraciously
working through their paperback novels
she actually talked at one point about
yeah she says I thought my mother was a
great aficionado of all science
fiction/fantasy
there were the galaxies later weird
tails and early novels
azimoff and clark these were well known
in our homes
the first fantasy story was conscious of
having read as such was the silken swift
by Theodore sturgeon I suppose that in
my early teens just as I read Mary
Reynolds the king must die when I was 11
ish and she here's a really interesting
thing that she said these wonders were
like finding a major truth of books just
as first hearing just just a Kovich
Prokofiev and Rachmaninoff was like
finding music I'd always known but
somehow mislaid have been robbed of so
she was you know you know reading all
this literature some of it was you know
contemporary fantasy and sci-fi some of
it was mythological stuff some of it was
history's or other other things and she
felt the kind of kinship or familiarity
with with as she's going into it and her
writing process reflects that too we'll
talk about that in a bit so coming back
to her story she starts writing stories
and she said that the first really
serious thing that she did was actually
a play that was when she was a bit older
and in the 1960s she starts you know one
one she actually you know finishes high
school she works and and then it's hard
to find any like hard dan about when
these different things happen she starts
working in different jobs none of what
she likes as a matter of fact there's a
really crazy line of this intergalactic
interview where she's talking about
being allowed to be a writer and so we
may as well go through this so she says
in the beginning I had no idea I would
ever be allowed to make my profession
that of a writer and then the sad
mindset I was encouraged to say by great
many persons for a great while so if I
had a plan that it was only for a
wretched sort of survival doing other
work at which I was largely incompetent
so that would be this you know library
assistant file clerk waitressing you
know sort of menial jobs and she says
where my unhappiness was matched only by
Mike
fusion she's you know supporting herself
but she she's she's no good at what she
does and she says when I was about 21
this condition almost drove me mad
through all of it I kept writing since
to me that was the only sanity at
bedrock in my life it was the only real
place to go when I was finally rescued
for my false working life by Don woolum
and DA books I had no sense of wildness
or charging off any rails I had none of
the reported fear of being unable to
cope with my new situation it was the
former situation that I was unable to
cope with so it's liberating for her she
doesn't have that like Oh am I do we
call this impostor syndrome these days
right am I really a writer she was like
yeah I'm a writer this other stuff all
sucks and I can't do this yeah so she
you know she's writing constantly and
she manages to sell this 90 word
vignette it's her first published first
paid for publication in this ninth pan
book of horror stories that I know
nothing about and then she's got this
friend who prints he's screwing around
with his own printing press do you guys
know this story
she's so he printed out six copies
apparently of one of her novels and he
was you know you sort of like an amateur
at this sort of thing so they become
collectors items and one I think is in
the Royal Library and the others kind of
circulate her out and now they're worth
incredible amounts of money you know
just because they didn't do too much of
it she goes to art college and she she
finds that she's got sort of a I won't
say sour grapes but sort of one of those
justifications for it at one point she
says listen I couldn't get grants and
that that wouldn't you know permit me to
stay at this art school but the other
thing that she does say is that she
preferred working with words to working
with with painting and
things like that and the whole time
she's continuing writing you notice
she's able to sell a few things the
early things are mostly kids books and
she she's trying to find the home for
this birth grave book and finally she
you know encounters dog which is going
to publish many of her books throughout
her career and at that point she decides
she's gonna start freelancing and work
as a full-time writer and then we find
out that she actually you know that's
that's the only thing she thinks you
suited for as a matter of fact she says
a little bit later deprived me of of
writing and my backup plan even now will
be the empty stormy darkened hearth you
know that's it you know I can't do
anything other than that yeah they say
he yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah I
was thinking like the fireplace hearth
yeah apparently though she would have
been wandering the Moors or something
and you know there's not a lot of other
biographical stuff that you see at the
timeline I mean there's a cool cool
things like doing radio plays she was
she was interested in that around 79 in
80 she's doing branching out a bit
writing some well yeah have any of you
seen that that show I looked at a little
bit of stuff is it any good I have a
feeling that it's one of those long-form
shows where if I were to devote serious
time to like starting to start to finish
watching all the episodes that they go
by maybe I would enjoy it more but
essentially it's like an SF version of a
kind of a weird sort of one-act play
where I think takes place in the same
sort of room and everyone sort of Erin
she's certainly angry
and it feels very 70s in British with a
space thing right it is what's almost
70s in British it's this very sort of
grim working class space mutiny kind of
story
oh it's okay but it's its main theme so
far as I've experienced them a few
episodes that I've seen and I've only
seen a few is betrayal and people being
angry and betrayed and sort of simmering
lis furious with one another for long
form things that they are old in grudges
and pedestrians and that like giving
each other the silent treatment in many
cases like throughout the episode like
slowly sort of doing it British sort of
picking at each other or like wow this
is very pointed sort of way of saying
something that indicates that you know
that you feel that this person is not
worthy of you it's so Pinterest but it's
not fun to watch
I didn't enjoy anything episode to us it
felt very yeah ready yeah well she only
wrote two episodes I mean and when I
went to check this out they they have
like their own wiki and stuff of their
own their own page and they were talking
about Dagon they did an interview with
her about writing those those episodes
I mean you notice she doesn't do that
afterwards but she's churning out a book
after book after book and including some
of the ones from from this series and
she starts you know I only put the work
the awards that she won she was
nominated for a ton of awards but but
often didn't get it but she does win
World Fantasy Award and then an 87 she
meets that the guy who's going to become
her husband John and I'm not sure how
his name is pronounced Kane perhaps and
he seems you know looking at the
pictures of him and pictures of the
together he seems to have been kind of
why
guy well you see him dressed in pirate
outfits and you know gallivanting around
there he was a writer in his own
respectin and so there's plenty of
material out there I'm the guy he's
still alive too although he must be you
know if he was the same age as her he's
getting up there now she dies in 2015
you know when I mentioned too that
there's so many obituaries of her out
there
and it's unfortunate too because they
all tend to link to her internet page
which now no longer exists because you
know in the age of the Internet if you
don't keep up your what is it owning the
the web page somebody else takes it up
and the page for her it's got some
Indian you know writing on it I can't
make out any anything on the page to
tell you what it would be even
somebody's squatting on it apparently so
there's nothing there and same thing for
the few other Tanith lead websites as
well in any case in the 80s there's a
special Tanith lee edition of weird
tales you know she's still churning out
the work but it's taking her more time
to do it she marries John in 92 later on
in her life in 2009 she gets a world
horror convention grandmaster award and
then a Life Achievement World Fantasy
Award and then you know in her 60s
she has a few bouts of breast cancer and
I've actually won one does kill her in
her home and she has some interesting
things to say about what would happen
with her career so she says this was
during the middle of her problems she
says most of the so-called big
publishers are unwilling even to look at
a proposal they aren't interested in
seeing anything from me not even those
houses I've worked with for many years
where any slight interest in my turning
and a work exists I
I must work within certain defined
formula and to me that's one of the arch
inspiration Stranglers I have at this
time no new book adults or young adult
either out or due to come out let alone
any contract to produce a book for any
of the main companies and besides that
only a couple of things are scheduled to
appear from small if reputable and
elegant houses I must and that doesn't
stop me from actually writing writing is
one of the most important things in my
life and so far a cupboard stocked with
reading completed never published novels
contemporary horror to original story
collections and proposals for four books
to them adult fantasies I'm just now
finishing another novel so she was
churning out literature and she couldn't
sell it and and why not well we were
talking about this a little bit before
in in the 90s in particular I mean it
started happening in the 80s but it was
really more in the 90s they they wanted
the publishing house would start playing
it safe they wanted things to very
clearly defined genres and you know part
of it I think it has to do with things
as you know mundane is the cost of paper
going up I remember growing up in the
70s and the 80s going to drugstores
which is one of the main places you
would buy fantasy and science fiction
books and so you would go to the you
know those turning what are the you know
like yeah now kiosks but racks yeah and
he would you would see these books and
you know some of them would be about
this thick and some of them would be
about this thick and when I was pretty
young a book about this thick would be
25 cents and then it went up to 50 cents
and then I went up to 75 cents and then
by the time that I was in high school a
book like this would run you you know
three dollars or 350 in a book like this
would cost you anywhere from five to
seven dollars and you know how did they
go up that much is it inflation it was
partly inflation every
was costing more you know gum costs more
milk cost more but paper in particular
cost more and more and so I think that
was one element and I think a lot of it
also was just you know in the 1980s
there's all this business activity and
consolidation and and you know trying to
make things as lean as possible and by
the 90s that's really hitting the book
industry and so the publishers they want
to know ahead of time that if they're
going to publish your stuff they're
gonna make money on it and they probably
would have made money on anything that
that Lee had but they they couldn't wrap
their heads around is it fantasy as a
gothic is it horror is it this is it
that and she she didn't like to to stick
with genres as a matter of fact at one
point she said the only genres that I
really recognize our fiction and
nonfiction
there's a nice passage in here about
maybe it said maybe I didn't put it into
that she talks about children's books
and she says I don't even think that
here we go yeah she dismissed the idea
that children should be viewed as a
distinct audience in need of a different
style of right so think about the whole
you know young adult phenomenon right
that's become its own like uber genre
you've got young adult fantasy young
adult horror I mean there's probably
young adult mercenary novels and you
know romance novels stuff like that and
she said the OL for her she thought the
only limits are sex for reasons of
censorship and violence for reasons of
common sense she didn't want to write to
kids in a different way than she did to
adults she just wanted to you know
narrow the purview of what could go in
there so you know maybe not so much
you know discussing demons seducing
people in the first few pages of
unicorn series which was in the Y a
section but there's a guy who has mouths
where his eyes should be so that's kind
of scary
yes it was very much stuff so so yeah
she didn't do the outright sex and
violence yeah you know if we think about
this if you had to pick a genre to put
her in could you do it could you
shoehorn her in any way into dark
fantasy no I think we talked about this
last time what define something as dark
fantasy is there is there a big agree to
fund
he's pretty dark he's adventuresome but
is pretty dark he stuff is pretty dark
okay okay well one of the other people
Carla were Wagner right would fit in
that gonna have the Kane series that
we're gonna look at later on his stuff
super dark but I mean he's writing
before I think that that distinction is
there is there a definition for it yeah
to differentiate yeah the dark fantasies
more disturbing yeah was it aimed is
that the the intent behind it - I don't
know it's like well Ted Williams when he
started was just fantasy the green you
know series but when he got into the
other world series Oh God that got
really dark in his No
that virtual reality okay and then his
more recent series is really dark
so he he shifted moments establish yeah
he's he shifted to be but much darker
you know I imagine that some of it
depends just for certain of these
authors on getting the room to maneuver
right first you got like be able to sell
books and and have people paying you
regularly then you can start writing the
stuff that you you want or the stuff you
want to play with yeah I you know this
is a bit off-topic here but I was
talking with somebody recently about
Stephen King and I was a big fan of that
king and his early stuff and those were
all you know short books like about this
thick yeah because that was all they you
got yeah once they started getting
really thick it was because he'd become
you know a big author and it seemed like
their quality went down like like you
know he wasn't gonna allow people to
challenge and you know be editors
cutting and stuff like that I don't
really know enough about it to to just
speculate do more than speculate well
when you talk about dark fantasy but
Game of Thrones in that category I was
gonna say give me five homes I would put
there except it's also low fantasy is it
slow well which might like oh I think
dark fantasy tends to have okay but yeah
otherwise like tone-wise tone wise and
with the dragons in that you know it has
very dark tone to it yeah I'm the White
Walkers part the White Walkers part well
there's a lot of characters you know
giving giving either terrible cynical
advice or or despair during other people
yeah just because because Martin you
know the way he tells us stories you're
inside the head
a lot of the characters and there's a
lot of dialogue between them and much of
the time you've got you've got like the
idealistic characters who think that
there's still some values and then
they'll be like somebody else saying kid
you don't you don't understand oh yeah
yeah you know so actually let's jump
into one of the themes that I wanted to
hit on when it comes to her characters
there there are some who are morally
good but they don't often remain so you
know they start out being good or even
you might say innocent or untarnished
but you let them get a little bit of
power and then they start to decline
that I'm thinking in particular I am
really bad with remembering the names of
the different women if there's the one
who she asked yeah exactly yeah she is
she's the she's originally quite quite
sweet too good and she's healing people
and then she once she becomes a queen
she's one of the worst worst people you
know in all the stories and I think that
that Lee sees that as as part of what
happens with with characters she talks
about she talks about this at one point
oh yeah that's right yes for me everyone
I write of Israel I wanted to talk about
that as well in terms of like her it's
kind of an interesting idea that the
writing and the stories are in some
respect more real with the BS mundane
jobs that she has to do I have little
say in what they want what they do or
end up as there
AXA polish aunt discussed roast down me
there add-ins fill me with retributive
Glee or break my heart I can only take
credit in recording the scenario this is
not a disclaimer just effect it hurt her
whole writing style you know when we
fact about like contrasting Tolkien as
the architect type you know everything
is planned out I've doubted like what
languages they they speak and what their
genealogy is and comparing that to like
Martin who describes himself as a
gardener Lee would be like an uber
gardener you know Martin at least has
character arcs plotted out people asked
her do you like you know you've got
complicated stories do you plot out what
the characters in milk I just write him
rarely edit very much and she talks
about them coming from her back brain
she uses that phrase quite a lot so it's
almost as if the characters are doing
what they're doing and she's watching
them and then writing writing it down
sort of like a chronicler by HG Wells
can be like that too it was in fact
accused of the time of writing a night
short stories but anecdotes is dumb you
were overhearing something somebody was
telling somebody or entrance the article
about like there'll be interesting ideas
and it's the stories like you know where
they saying that about stories like the
Invisible Man and my machine time
machine is guy I mean this is short
stories especially getting before it but
but even so as his novels have this
quality of being a bit like a newspaper
article you were reading about something
that had occurred and he got really up
in arms about it you know you would say
according to my by critics the short
story is ma possum the anecdote is
demonym with because they were
essentially claiming that it didn't
count as a story it was it was more like
something that ought to replace no
difference
that's interesting but he brought up
YouTube all Pisans
yeah because he writes these stories
that are pretty short yeah you know
answer to actually yeah they're fun I
like reading them they're pretty dark it
was I guess it was him sort of trying
pointing on these people trying to make
as people have been doing down through
the ages this dividing line between
literary and oh yeah yeah I mean Lee
could easily be defended on literary
grounds just by the sort of like
gorgeousness of her her writing you know
that's richness I think some people have
a problem with it is it again a little
bit of life topic we'll come back to
this character thing some people
probably have a problem with it because
they view it as you know pornographic
you know there's a lot of sex involved
and it's described and very
matter-of-fact terms but it doesn't seem
like it's just there to titillate it's
you know it's usually part of the story
you know and it's you know that was one
of the things to I remember about like
when I was a kid and reading science
fiction and fantasy in the 70s and 80s
especially here came you know that's had
quite repressive Wisconsin you know if
there was a sex scene you or can't
you're paying attention to it because it
might be telling you how things actually
work and I don't think you'd get any
really bad ideas from her stuff you know
I remember like reading and it was the
guy with the Thomas Covenant series
Stephen Donaldson oh yeah and reading
that being like wow sex you know is this
what it's like it really sounds terrible
here's Anthony isn't it more and we're
gonna be talking about him I think next
month isn't it more like he's he's kind
of flippant about it right yeah okay he
put a story the only story I disliked in
Harlan Ellison's edited collections
dangerous visions story in there called
in the barn which takes place in his
dystopian future in which women are
being raised to be essentially like a
kind of animal oh it has this flipping
hole stop livestock yeah okay this
flipping quality about it if somebody
trying to do something specifically for
the purpose of squeaking you out oh
thank you too many dad sleeping with
babysitters for my taste so yeah yeah I
mean I haven't read him for quite a long
time and we are going to look at the
some of the xanthe nominees next month
I do remember there being quite a lot of
sex in those you know yeah because
there's like a coherent world so coming
back to the like moral development you
know I was reminded of this passage in
Mary Wollstonecraft who's got the
vindication of the rights of women she's
talking about bashfulness because she's
got this entire chapter on whether
modesty should be regarded as a virtue
primarily for women or whether modesty
should be reinterpreted so that it's no
longer about sexuality and it's more
about you know like the proper place
between humility and pride and she
talked about like George Washington
being modest in this respect you know or
other important leaders and she then she
there's this passage where she's talking
about bashful
she says bashfulness is actually a
terrible quality and she's talking about
you know as a Londoner she's talking
about these country girls coming in from
the outside and they you know they
seemed very innocent because they've
never learned anything you know and you
know as soon as they do start learning
anything they're you know immediately
flipped over to the other side
innocence isn't really a good quality
for for Wollstonecraft because it means
you don't you know you're only acting
good you don't know any better it's when
you actually understand the world and
then you do it you know what's good or
what's best or you have the right the
right a choice exactly yeah yeah and so
I'm thinking about some of her
characters many of them are good so long
as they're innocent or bashful in that
sense then once they start getting
exposed to what power gives them or you
know they experience some terrible loss
and I want revenge or something like
that they can they can become quite
vicious I don't know of too many
characters who start out good and remain
good throughout the entire okay well it
doesn't have to be you know where
goodness pays off but but retaining
goodness yeah so I think we talked about
like there's a sort of corrosive effect
the longer year round for the the the
more the different things that are
enticing can pull you pulling you into
that or it could be a polar it could be
it could be like a a pusher response
where it's anger that that drives a
person
certain direction you know but I thought
that was kind of an interesting feature
there aren't you know we do have other
fantasy and science fiction novels where
nobody's really a good guy you know it's
very gray even even though they're
really bad guys you know like death you
know the Lord of the demons they're not
truly bad he does do self-sacrifice to
save the world at the end of the first
book
yeah am bishop has a series where you
get that kind of thing with the
characters Fremont what kind of thing
with where he's the bad characters is
the character really bad or is it it
looks bad maybe they're really not and
what else they're gonna direction I
found it's very entertaining but they
are different
yeah they're different george RR martin
in the Song of Ice and Fire has a few
characters like that particularly Jaime
Lannister who in the show you know they
just screwed up again but the show is so
far off book but if it in the you know
he you're supposed to hate him in the
first book and he throws bran out of the
tower and he's just complete you know
bastard and then he kills Ned Stark's
retainers and he's using his wonderful
sword talents for evil but then there's
this this Redemption arc in his
our actions with Brienne of Tarth yeah
yeah I think it's totally out of time
but man did they really screw that up
with the show doing this season they had
to do something cuz he'd ever finished
the other book you know he might though
he's one of these years it was to make
up that's what's happening man and now
that be I think the man was finally
finished they've released a new anime
version so quickly Game of Thrones would
need to be filmed in a few years
yeah you know that's that's kind of an
interesting thing that we've never
really talked about that much when
you've got because we've also talked
about books right when you've got
multiple genres of multiple media of the
same basic world of characters and they
start to diverge from each other which
one do you trust and which one is
canonical I think with with george RR
martin you know there's those of us
who've read the books but I think most
people they think that HBO series is the
canonical one in part because it's
coming to an end whereas he hasn't been
successful in in executing that way
Kenneth Lee none of her stuff ever got
adapted for TV so it would be good for
it right okay Nick I was wondered about
that
Michael Moorcock - I think that'd make a
great sum of whose material a great
television yeah I mean it would be
pretty trippy to do the Cornelius
Chronicles maybe not that probably have
to be like a cartoon yeah we oughta make
a better crunching but I think you could
do something now oh yeah yeah I don't
know why I nobody's ever done it and
it's pretty dark I think it'd be hard I
think they'd be difficult to write that
in a way that is this is the 3d
rebooting yes it is I can see I can see
networks and yeah the cable networks not
so much yeah but I could see up until
what we're getting into NamUs networks
and developers having difficulty
figuring out how to do that in a way
that's accessible - yeah the majority
audience she talks about somebody whose
name was adapted kind of successfully by
the sci-fi Network who's she I mean and
and and it's interesting if we want to
think about like who does Lea resemble
peak I think is one of them because he
also has that that very gorgeous like
it's almost like he's doing watercolors
with his words sort of writing and then
of course you know I think in some
respect so there's the the fros aspect
of it and then at the what depictive
nosov it and then the the picaresque
sort of like stories leading into
stories that she's very much like jackie
dance in that way - right but so this is
what she says about Mervyn Peake she
says I think generally Mervyn Peake is
still not properly valued his incredible
three-volume epic of the grown dynasty
and their habitat habitat Gormenghast is
unique in that words true meaning there
was nothing like it and where there is
some what now that's due only to the
exquisite influence of his work on
others he wrote like no one else he was
and is a voice that though I suppose
that his copyable stays unreachable his
structures words images
his moon high eliminations and abysmal
shadows are frankly inimitable he breaks
the rules all this was that's right
is a conversation about the weird he
breaks the rules even of weird while
remaining one of the kings of it here
and there peek can admittedly be a dense
of forest and read but these passages
are too like a graceful movie of perfect
camerawork and lighting like paintings
coming calmly into life or riotously and
you know she's actually doing quite a
good job of that sort of prose herself
in describing him in this interview
unclearly he must have been an influence
on upon her that that's what would we
call it not genre in that style right of
writing so let's talk let's go back to
shot she's sort of punished because she
doesn't finish that well we're in a time
when it seems like even more than the
90s the publishing industry really wants
people not only in writing but even and
everything else think about music we
should be able to classify the genre the
air you're working in in many respects
there's all these different little
subdivisions that people make notes of
it you know maybe maybe we're at a time
when genre is really becoming a stifling
you know it's it's keeping people from
being able to branch out and do what
they want unless they can unless of
course they just self publish or
whichever is really much of an option
and you know the time that she was
worried about it was so early in her
career you know
reminded me of home I can't pronounce
her name and a new husband bought a
printing press and started their own yes
Oh interesting I didn't know that I
don't think it's just this genre it
despite the publishing industry trying
to force genre yeah I'm in two other
book clubs and we run into all the time
where does this fit yeah cuz it doesn't
lots of books they may be classified
historical fiction or they classified a
certain way yeah but when you actually
read them it's like wait a minute this
is more than that this has got different
aspects to it yeah it's not a single Oh
John not a single thing really
noteworthy standout novels tend to have
that aspect to him I was like Neil
Gaiman 'he's description of the use of
genres that he said it's what tells you
what you want to evoke store what i was
not to go to in fact if you're looking
to have something by Stephen King it
might be in literary fiction or maybe
you know where fiction is probably not
any romance yeah yeah thinking about
bookstores I don't I don't go and flip
stores anymore except for used
bookstores and I remember like going in
places like Walden books or a Barnes &
Noble and always being a little ticked
off when I would go to the philosophy
section cuz I mean look at it I'd be
like half of this crap is in philosophy
and then I you know look at other places
I'd be like this belongs in the
philosophy section but you know I guess
it just depends on where you know
something on the back of the book that
tells where it's supposed to go
you know my favorite bookstore is a used
bookstore in Door County and that just
has shelves everything is alphabetical
by authors last name no I've been in
there not a fiction to split up a bit
more I think they do have some children
yaa like
that's sort of like treating everything
as if it's classics though right yeah
you just fiction is fiction
yes yeah well that kind of fits leaves
you know view on it you know fictions
are all just fictions and and for her
Eve and you know as we've seen with some
of these these passages it's not even
clear that fiction is completely
fictional you know seems like she
believes that like the Greek myths and
Celtic myths and certain aspects of
Christianity she's kind of down a lot of
aspects of Christianity but then there
were parts that she thought were quite
good they're all just as real as you
know the technology that we have or the
tables or you know clothing were wearing
the job that we have to go to but I
don't think it was just her like trying
to avoid reality I think that that's the
way she actually thought about things so
another theme that I thought could be
interesting to talk about it's sort of
like the elephant in the room for the
whole series is she's she's got
personifications of fundamental forces
right so death death actually be
personified and she talks about you know
like at one point you know how she was
going to frame it in the western
traditions death is often pictured is
masculine and many Eastern traditions
death is pictured as as feminine and but
there's there's some sort of agency
there and and you know death is a
character who has I don't know can we
say that death actually has desires
maybe not but certainly he seems to want
people
yeah I guess because those could be
desires right yeah already some in some
writings you see death had portrayed is
someone who views his role as
maintaining order yeah that takes a
holiday the movie does takes a holiday
without death oh yeah things go really
wrong Terry Pratchett doesn't that mr.
Cratchit doesn't in this world so death
has a role in terms of maintaining the
order in the world it wasn't me he sort
of didn't choose to come into existence
he's there because people personify
death and even go undergoes a major
personality change
yeah over the course of this book that
he used to be indifferent but
compassionate nasty do you think that's
an important distinction like the demon
lord and I'm really bad with names
he pre-existed humanity okay death
delirium right there they come into
being with humanity humanity because of
I guess because of deaths case just
because humanity's mortal but delirium
maybe because humanity's screwed up
bring them into to being they don't have
a choice about it it's forced upon them
do you think that's an important
distinction there may they're all at war
all right yeah it might be morally
speaking for some of them like the lord
of madness to it you'd expect to sort of
dislike them
bringing bad things but they're not
doing it out of malice they're just yeah
and that's that's another thing that
when we we personify we had to expand it
beyond the ones that are talking about
here I think about like the old notion
that the Greek gods or other you know
polytheistic systems what people are
really personifying are either forces of
nature or social dynamics in some way or
aspects of humanity like you know the
NSS represents getting screwed up and
and excess and having a good time but
also maybe you know driving your car
through the you know the flower garden
or something like that right and Apollo
represents a whole bunch of different
functions you know including prophecy
and order and archery and and things
like that
Herbies represents being a messenger but
also being kind of a roguish thieving
guy you know and you know if you if you
say well they're like you know the top
person in this respect so you know
thieves would like be connected with
with Hermes or mercury or whatever the
equivalent yeah in other pantheon ins
it's going to be some other trickster
sort of sort of fellow can the trickster
is the trickster really an agent and how
they're being a trickster they can't not
be that that's their essence right that
sound like they're choosing human beings
could like choose why I I'm done with
being a screw-up who like you know takes
everybody's
launch out of the refrigerator I'm now
going to be the reliable person you know
and like rise through the ranks I go
from being burped Hermes of mercury to I
don't know
Zeus or somebody else who's not a
screw-up another personification may
a lot more to do with he said earlier
reflecting human nature as a human
nature because every month every strain
of mythology yeah a trickster yeah every
strain of mythology has a lord of lords'
the top god every strain of mythology
has my goddess of love of some kind
every stream is and every single one of
them has an underworld day usually
somebody who's like the super warrior
there's always that element no matter
whether you're looking at Celtic
mythology Norse mythology Roman Greek
Native American yeah they all have those
general characteristics those general
characters yeah I mean they're usually
tends to be some difference in emphasis
and then a couple other like wildcards
during it as well even even in Hindu
religion the characters the Pantheon
there and they there's but they pull out
aspects of human yeah
nature yeah and so and those all
developed independent of each other
generally yeah yeah generally generally
speaking yeah so it has to be more when
I look at it I see more about humanity
looking at human nature and taking
pieces of it and saying well what's this
way there's also I think there's a turn
towards the natural world too and trying
to figure out where the forces that we
have to respect or that play a role you
know think about like famine coming
about because of a lack of growth
in the grain so you get it something
some other way of connecting those and
then they're usually connected together
right so like in ancient Greek you know
traditional Pantheon which was kind of
fluid
you've got dammit her and she's juices
sister but she's also in terms of grain
and stuff like that and when the
daughter gets stolen she can screw
harvests up and all of that although you
know in that case we've got death
walking around with things right because
it's Hades who steals our away and you
know Persephone winds up becoming the
queen of the underworld
she didn't intend to be but that sort of
forced upon her Greeks it to God's
Awards which is unique what's up the
Greeks have 2004 as well that's amore
yeah well yeah I don't know if that's
unique
well oh god I should say I'm not
familiar with it seemed like two
different aspects for us on that were
two different aspects of conflict if we
broaden it further Erik Aries definitely
is a God of War but he's like a god one
thirstiness right
those were slogging you don't throw
people with the problems yeah yeah yeah
I think she's also just very Aries isn't
you know I mean even look at the other
stuff that Aries does like cheats out
his brother you know Sadducees and
brother's wife so that's kind of a big
no-no so that's a good segue into
talking about sexuality and it's
interesting because you know Lee gets
held up a lot as being a feminist author
and you know supporter of LGBTQ and
queer theory people really like her but
you know when you look at these these
stories I don't I don't get that she's
got like an agenda
I think she's the characters just
happened to be for the most part pretty
open to whatever is going to provide
them with pleasure and I think she she
kind of just sketched them out that way
and it happened to fit into a time when
you know all of these things are coming
to the before she actually I mean she
got an award for for one of those yeah
exactly yeah
and you know she was pretty progressive
in general but I don't I get the idea
that it's more than writing is drive
again and less some sort of agenda it's
more like this produces great stories
why not let people you know to be very
crude screw whoever they want you know
the characters want to do that sort of
thing blood up and I'm just curious to
what you know when all of you thought
about about that I was but yeah she does
make it feel really organic I think part
of it is because it's a very ancient
setting almost like yeah that's a way to
say is done I mean a lot of times it you
know a lot of these things feel forced
when people are like you know you've
kind of respect everybody and this is
just as legitimate as this and there's
none of that with her it's more just
like well here's what you got well and
there's a lot of talking her ear DS
about how she didn't plan it it's like
the characters just kind of came to life
yeah and where they went they went so
are you good I didn't mean to cut you
off
yeah organic yeah um just that it fit
the ancient setting cuz in the ancient
world you have cultures like Greece and
Rome
the Middle East where lots of people
were more bisexual with their
consumption before we invented
heterosexuality yeah I feel like she'll
reflected that pretty well
truce - yes the enemy could only come
there now the Greeks were quite
conflicted about it and I see this at
Plato's symposium there's a speech by
Pausanias who is the lover of one of the
other people him the thing he's the
lover of Phaedrus and Pausanias gives
this he's a legal expert so he gives us
this great speech right about how you
know the Athenians are right in the
middle and the they always everybody
likes the goldilocks formula right just
right not like those those stupid Bowie
Asians who let the guys you know just
force each other upon each other and
they're not very communicative but not
like those you know other people who are
who are you know to a feed or two
against this or thing the Athenians you
get to have sex with other guys but just
at the right time and in the right way
and he's not great at defining it but
there's this sense that like I mean I've
kind of joked sometimes like when I do
like write up some post ideas of speech
and entitlement there ought to be a law
because he's talking about how the
Athenian law it's still a little bit you
know it imprecise and it needs to be
tweaked a bit so you're have the right
kinds of lovers and all that but
underlying that is the notion that some
things that some things would be okay
it's just a matter of like figuring out
when it's beneficial or there's no like
this is the only way things can can
possibly go you know
that too there is a sense like people
have to be in such and such a
configuration or anything
yes characters who I mean it's
interesting that the the queen who plays
such a big role in the second book who
is who is a lesbian yes her pencil
Barisan yeah they they complain about
her for that reason a good bet yeah but
mostly was they needed a kid yeah yeah
it seemed another thing that said they
had a problem with her being a lesbian
before when she was just honest before
everything went wrong yeah cuz didn't
sack the supposed to recruiter like
specifically saying people are going to
start hating you for now that's right
yeah you're right which suggests that
they didn't have a problem with it
before yeah
quite true so and even when she slept
with the dead young man got the
seriousness um she seems to assume that
he was gay cuz when she kissed him she
said imagine this is like one of your
male lovers doing this yeah I'd
forgotten about that yeah
was there anything in his backstory that
would give us I would say these sort of
leaves assumption because he's described
as being beautiful or not sure that I
think there's a little bit of fact an
assumption there like it would be with
the ancient Greeks yeah I mean he's got
a big tough brother and there are some
wouldn't necessarily know that maybe it
was just
she assumed yeah or or the categories
you know just I'm in there you know I
mean I don't get the I don't get any
vibe from reading these that there's any
point where Tanith Lee is like now we
need to get character you know or
anything remotely like that and it does
it does fit in with what she's how she
describes her characters growing and
what happens with them I don't want to
read through this whole thing but she
there's this one where she's she's the
object of desire interview she says
sometimes there's only atmosphere or a
strongly seem mental image as I get into
a book or story a certain amount of not
planning more self discussion and
conjecture occur which are immensely
fascinating for me inspiration supplies
vast amounts of detail characters
arrived from nowhere and in many
scenarios the main characters the one
who appears first and foremost before
any real aspect of the plot becomes at
all clear very decidedly as around
prints of demons and the flat earth
sequence goes that way so maybe you know
maybe that just applies to everything
our characters do they you know come
into being they do what they do they
move along the vectors that she has for
them whatever else is impinging on her
life at the time or her thoughts at the
time gives you character arcs and they
do what they do you know which would
imply that that sexuality would just be
another form of the agency I guess right
I could it could be just as much than
making a million in cornering the market
although she doesn't talk much about
economic things it's just part of who
they are yeah exactly
what else the cosmology the Flat Earth
it plays a much lesser role would the
layers sometimes come in the second book
there's that becomes the well of
immortality because it's located
underneath the one in heaven yeah
so there's yet some geography in the
second book there's some of the others
it's just I mean you could ask the
question does it really need to be a
flat earth probably not right it's just
kind of a catchy phrase you know later
books I read something about it being a
flat earth prevents having polar regions
Oh
so all of its habitable oh okay she does
have lots of countries although exact
all of its habitable well sure there are
no oceans there are seas yeah okay
thanks for those other storms are there
like hurricanes and because no
hurricanes no major well then they just
answer you know jet stream either
there'd be no jet stream I mean how
would you get wind because there has to
be wind probably Arwen spirits yeah but
it provides a flat earth provides a
environment that is totally habitable I
think that also throws out a lot of our
assumptions about how things are
supposed to work like in the third book
there's a woman who's blessed because a
comic goes over
while their mother was pregnant with her
and the comet is actually a bit of Sun
that got blown off when the Sun rose
above the horizon no matter if and
basically if we were thinking about a
round earth existing in space with the
moon orbiting it an orbiting the Sun
we'd be like no this doesn't make sense
this is silly
wouldn't work because she just scrapped
everything we know our because she can
say whatever she wants so he could feel
like yeah that works yeah I mean I it's
kind of funny because I mean in the I
guess ancient times and some of them had
evils and some of the early modern they
did think of like the infernal regions
as being inside the gold you know now
this makes it super easy well you just
got these superimposed things you could
have as many of them as you want you
know she only exploits it to have
essentially four regions right there's
the yeah so but she could have had like
58 if she wanted to kind of smart design
future there reminds me a little bit a
Terry Pratchett doesn't he do that with
the Discworld yeah I'm a rebel there are
multiple discs oh if I remember right
I'd have to spent a long time I don't
want to contradict to you but I think
I've encountered that there was
something it's been a long time since
I've read it he did he did a book called
the long earth which has a similar
theory what multiple earths stacked next
to it that's what I'm thinking of where
like you can go round earth somewhere
well what it is is essentially their
their multiple dimensions which are
alternate versions of Earth that are
linked together so you can go west
essentially forever following it's a
very peculiar sort of like infinite
length but limited area okay
you might because that just came out
fairly recent Stephen Baxter yeah I care
much for it but the idea itself is
really intriguing
yeah that's finite though you think of a
Philip was a farmers yes I mean it's
fine they it's just set up in a very
ingenious way so the river winds back
and forth but then there's the mountains
you know preventing it and it is on the
corner the river winds up being really
really really long like yeah thirty
thousand miles long I think because of
the meandering yeah you know I think
that Bopha also had just beam up things
that are stacked next to each other he
had like I can't remember what the
science fiction explanation of it was
but it was like an infinitely long place
we just keep traveling in one direction
and I think you're also trapped on the
third time okay
well you know if you think about like
some of the games that are currently out
like my kids like playing Minecraft and
provided you have enough computing power
you could you know you could have a
world in which you could like head west
forever and never reach the end of the
generated say because it's creating
another's loss spacefaring games and
whether that called no man's sky I heard
that yeah but is that is that truly
infinity as a finite super super big I
know this system any capacity to
generate new material the further that
would be that would be interesting yeah
flutters kinda reminds me when I played
runescape online role-playing game their
map you could actually go to the edge of
the map and then I think in the West it
was just blackness okay it just like
this hasn't been there yet and in the
East it was this kind of haunted country
and you have this ocean that looks very
bleak but basically one they wanted to
add something new they just had
something to be edge of the map so the
flatness like that but the other aspect
of being a flat earth is it took a long
time to get around and I was actually
one of your tenth we was gonna make this
a plot point at some point you can't cut
around the short end of the globe if
something truly truly west there yeah
and she has characters wandering around
for months or years
and I feel like Oh be ironic she could
have happened at some point well she is
a really vast expanse of time too
and it's interesting because if you
think about not just cosmology but like
human culture really not a lot of change
happens right it's kind of a mishmash of
Western Medieval and Arabic / Near East
/ Central Asian and ancient cultures all
kind of blurred in one but there's no
technological developments or progress
in any real sense but they're clearly
there there's there was progress in the
past because there's all sorts of books
and you know things that you can do
right but none of that's really narrated
much in the backstory but maybe she
doesn't doesn't need it you know maybe
the goal is just to tell a great story
and maybe there isn't any ultimate you
know sort of a lot of series right
there's there's like there's some sort
of long-term plot I don't know if it
there actually is one at this there's
some like events right but there's a lot
of the ending of the first they're
mostly very contingent though right they
didn't have to turn out it's all like it
was that what came before we came after
couldn't have happened so necessary it's
well I was thinking it more like the the
parts that are connected to each other
are they really part of like a story an
overall story that has a theme to it
that makes sense
or is it just you know like I forget
exactly who said about this of history
just one damn thing after another the
damn things are connected to each other
this this damn thing couldn't happen if
this damn thing happened but but you
know who cares you know there could be
any other thing where is a lot of you
know fantasy or sci-fi or you know
whatever there's there's some
overarching plan or plot or conflict or
something like that being worked out
okay the story's truly are an ugly
character driven like she describes that
that would make sense though doesn't
have that yeah anything that's bill is
dictated by the actions of the
characters and so yeah I'm going to be a
sense of an overarching plot driving
things so much as decisions being made
at on top of other decisions the lords
are like trying to control things with
them they're fighting each others they
have counter mechanisms and every once
in a while a human just wants it then
the work some completely changes the
game yeah there are may need to be a
little bit of doing all this free
association with philosophy stuff but
David here has this great you know
dialogue concerning natural religion and
he's he's actually playing off of
somebody who he really liked who was
Cicero who set up an earlier three
different guys from three different
philosophical positions talked to each
other about religion in his father
nature of the gods a skeptic a stoic and
epicurean in Humes case you've got these
these other three guys and him is
playing them off against each other
they're very smart you know because he's
the ultimate skeptic
comes to this and he has one of them who
is a skeptic put forth a bunch of
hypotheses about the God saying you know
your your notion of like the traditional
monotheistic God that's only one
possibility for the cosmology that we
could have maybe this world was created
by the God who is sort of like an
apprentice and he you know this is a
crappy work that he screwed up maybe it
was made by a committee maybe it was
made by a God who was like almost senile
maybe it was made by a giant spider we
don't really know and when we imagine
the the divine beings you know there's
there's there's usually this like well
they must be so much better than honest
and smarter and they're whatever they're
doing must be amazing right and you
don't actually get that in here there's
you know there's the above world the
overworld no that's it that's inclusion
yeah yeah and and but the guys don't
seem particularly interesting or like
they do much of anything it's some
respect they're more like the epicurean
gods the Epicureans did believe that
God's existed but they thought that the
reason why the gods were happy was
because they didn't care at all about
human beings you know if they paid any
attention to us they'd have been
miserable I guess you know so better off
for the way they were blessed is they
don't do anything you know nothing of
consequence and you get kind of you get
the idea that the only the only you know
people who really matter are human
beings and then these demons of
different sorts and agents of death and
other other masters right so maybe that
also fits in with like the you know we
think of the whatever is in heaven it
has to be like the good guys right but
maybe they're just the boring guys you
know learn for these world Michael
Moorcock's gods and
turned out the same way to in which most
of the gods of law length on those are
fairly staid and don't have much of a
same story yeah it's been so long since
I've read any of that do they play a big
role in the Elric stories no like they
show up like very occasionally usually
to tell our that you know bad things are
going to happen like the one thing
that's like there's a God along and on
plus we chose of a couple times
basically to tell or account how scary
is but doesn't do much because the gods
of lawn their whole thing is that they
don't take actions yeah so that the gods
don't why do i they're just like bored
with earth like it's a game they set up
yeah i mean that that's a perfectly
possibly to go back to the humane thing
that's a perfectly possible possible
hypothesis here was point that he was
making as hey anything we can imagine
that's possible so we can't say once we
get beyond the realm of like experience
we have no better reason to buy into
this hypothesis then we do this
hypothesis or this one oh yeah so i
found the quote it's man is a mistake we
made all the time even gods are entitled
to one mistake will not catch you ate
another by saving him let him vanish
from the earth and earth vanish from the
state of being bad you're a demon of
humanities your beloved toy we have
reset graduated from such trivia yeah so
they just got bored and kind of wish the
whole thing would go away but then the
question is well what do they do you
know what what are they interesting yeah
i think there's any answer the
implication might be that they're doing
something that humans and demons can't
even comprehend like their palaces are
so psychic thought that are almost
invisible yeah so whatever their
lifestyle isn't something that people
just can't understand and can't ascend
to right there's no there's no
possibility of developing and connecting
to that sort of thing which you couldn't
depict anyway I mean we talked about
this was like Arthur Clarke and
childhood and you know what that's one
of the problems and depicting these
these sorts of resolutions I suppose
well what else what are the are there
any other themes that you thought were
particularly central to this I mean I
came up with a few any other
philosophical themes that you thought
were gripping you or there's some
question about justice or sometimes
occurs yeah the grad student sort of in
crisis for the reader about like do
people deserve this
the fates that they have yeah and when
certain events start happening in
lockstep that you look like back where
did this all begin I mean there are
characters who rendered justice in some
way but the you can like raise it to
another level and say well is that
justice that they give actually just but
but there's no there's no like criterion
and we're brought up and any of them
works as far as I can tell
yeah there's a lot of disproportionate
retribution you know a lot of anger yeah
I think
Florizel is like the one person who
finally I think it's justice because the
blind man
and they finds out about her and wants
to help her and then they didn't make
their way out and then in the last
section of Knights Master a human curses
as her own and he kind of laughs it off
because he's the father of all curses he
can't be cursed that's right then as
part of that same plotline that's what
eventually ends up to him having to
incinerate himself to save the world
so my Cobra theory is that the kid the
curse actually did come home for them
temporarily you know going back to that
like personification of forces the whole
thing about hate it starts out as a
human being being thwarted and his body
ends up dying but the hate lives on and
it gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
it turns everybody against each other so
I guess there there's the possibility
it's not daya fication as such yeah
that's a really good way to put it
becoming some sort of thing and they're
not just presents yeah sort of thing
with a capital T you know the big things
that matter in life like law or death or
hay or fate or these these big concepts
that we bring up but it's so human being
can can become one so I mean becoming
hate doesn't sound like such a great
fate it's not like becoming a I don't
know compassion or joy the guy himself
became hate itself was independent we
came an energy of its own yeah yeah but
it happened that had been it's working
his passion yeah right so yeah I guess
it isn't his that if his soul turned
into the hate I think she would
don't follow those up but what happens
to people's souls true so the way she
mentioned it I got the impression that
they split off or although maybe the
soul was just consumed well what else do
want to bring up or talk about or
reflect upon anything else coming to
mind otherwise we can we can end a bit
early oh just in listening as we're
talking about I'm just looking it up
it's been a long time since I read it
but it reminded me of Doris Lessing
series Canopus in Argos in terms of who
controls what she created a series got a
lot of criticism because it was her
first science-fiction series
and her followers her readers were used
to her writing fiction yeah and all of a
sudden she wrote this five book series
which is pure science fiction but it's a
a world CH acosta which is allegorical
earth but it's controlled by three
galactic empires and there's a there's a
concept of maybe humanity came out of an
experiment that failed and there's a lot
of throughout the five books there's a
lot of back-and-forth about morality and
experimentation and power there's a
tremendous amount of that I was looking
it up cuz it's been a long time since I
read it it's been decades since I read
that might be one to do next year you
know she draws on the Old Testament in
some ways and she draws on Eastern
spirituality in other ways it's not an
easy read it's a complicated but there's
a coherent world as a coherent set over
the coherent set of worlds okay
career universe
and the general structure is based on
reports from agents of these empires on
the status of this experiment basically
interesting so it gets a little out
there in spots yeah it's a little a
little you know you have to wade through
it a little bit in spots but I remember
enjoying it when I read it didn't you
get away through this though quite often
begin just part because it's so rich you
know there's some books for you read
them and you you know you're in bed
reading and you're staying up very late
because you can't stop turning pages you
know to find out what's going on next
and usually that those are can
effortless this I I don't I found I had
to come work to read it I didn't want to
put it down
I still don't I was engaged in the
stories but the whole time it was like I
was you know working out yeah looks like
a rich meal you don't have to know at
the end of a chapter you'd be able to
put the book down so yeah each to the
weigh station yeah but and it is like a
rich man you can't just like keep
shoveling the stuff into
you know call it or else you're gonna
get sick
well she made sure we call it a
nightmare
[Music]